If we analyze
the teachings of most of the major
religion,
many of them are similar. For example,
all the major religions say there should
not steal, there should not rob,
Hinduism says that, Judaism says that,
Christianity says that, Islam says the
same. So what's the difference between
Islam and the other major religions? The
difference is Islam besides speaking
about the good things, it shows you a
way how to achieve that goodness.
For example, Islam besides saying that
you should not cheat, besides saying you
should not steal, you should not rob, it
shows you a way how to achieve a state
in which people will not steal, people
will not rob.
Islam first speaks about zakat.
Zakat means it is the third pillar of
Islam that every rich human being
every rich Muslim
by the saving of more than the nisab
level more than 85 g of gold he or she
should give 2.5%
of that excess wealth in charity every
lunar year. This is called a zakat. If
every rich human being in the world
gives zakat, poverty will be eradicated
from this world. There will not be a
single human being who will die of
hunger.
After this,
the Quran says in surah Maida chapter
number five, verse number 38, as to the
thief,
be it a male or a female, chop of his or
her hand as a punishment from Allah
subhanaa tala.
Now after saying give charity if after
that someone
steals someone robs
Allah says as for the thief be it a man
or a woman chop off his or her hand as a
punishment from Allah.
You know today the country which has the
maximum theft and max one of the highest
rate of crime in the world it is which
country?
It is USA
one of the highest rate of crime and
theft. I'm asking you the question that
if you implement this rule of Sharia in
USA that every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level of
more than 85 g of gold should give 2.5%
of his saving every lunar year in
charity and after that if any man steals
any man robs chop of his or her hand as
a punishment. I'm asking you the
question will the rate of theft in USA
will it increase will it remain the same
or will it decrease
>> will decrease it's simple you don't have
to be a PhD to know this answer the
moment you implement the Sharia you get
results
therefore I say Islam besides talking
about good things besides preaching good
things shows you a way how to achieve
that state in which People will not
steal, will not rob.
Let me give you one more example for a
better understanding. Most of the
religion they say that you should not
tease a girl, you should not molest a
girl, you should not rape a girl.
Hinduism says that, Christianity says
that, Islam says the same. So what is
the difference between Islam and the
other religions? The difference is Islam
beside telling you that you should not
tease or molest or rape a woman, it
shows you a way how to achieve a state
in which people will not molest or rob.